wow
welcome to Hannity we are back we are
live in New York City with a live
audience what a great
peace
wow okay
wow what a great crowd thank you all for
coming uh so glad and I took the red eye
back from the Reagan Library last night
and I'm not even tired hanging out with
this group all right
all right coming up tonight Tommy Lauren
tutor Dixon Jimmy Bayla Texas governor
Greg Abbott they're all going to be
sitting right here
but first we have a pathetic new chapter
from your President Joe Biden and it's
now unfolding before our eyes day one of
the house impeachment inquiry into Biden
what I call the Joe Biden bribery and
money laundering uh Scandal allegations
it is now in the books it's officially
started it did not disappoint let's
start and take a look bank records
obtained this week showed that on August
2nd 2019 Jonathan Lee and Miss Tain Ling
in Beijing sent Hunter Biden 250 000
listing Joe Biden's home address in
Wilmington Delaware the wire stated it
was for a personal investment
the Biden family and Associates received
um over 20 million dollars from 23
different countries that they had
business ties to or Communications with
and they also had over 20
um shell llc's where they would transfer
money in and out this is a text message
between Jim Biden and Hunter Biden
Hunter Biden was in a bad way by the way
he was he was really strung out he lost
a bunch of money he needed help Jim
Biden says this can work you need a safe
harbor
I can work with your father alone this
is a text message between Hunter Biden
and gongwen Dong an agent of cefc Hunter
says my uncle will be here with his
brother in all caps who would like to
say hello to the chairman he goes on
Jim's brother if he's coming wants to
say hello his uncle's brother
I wonder who that could be I can't quite
figure it out by the way the Mob of the
media and all these Democrats there's no
evidence no there's a mountain of
evidence anyway it would take us hours
to play all the evidence presented just
today against Joe Biden there are bank
records there are tax records we have
170 suspicious activity reports we've
got photographs we've got text messages
we have WhatsApp messages I'm sitting
next to my father you will regret
between everyone he knows and my ability
to hold the grudge not following through
anyway we have emails eyewitness
accounts we have born testimony
whistleblower testimony and at least one
damning FBI 1023 form from a highly
credible FBI Source quoting directly the
CEO of barisma admitting to giving 5
million to one Biden 5 million to
another Biden that would be called
bribery where I grew up I don't know
what you call it where you grow up or a
Shakedown use whatever term you like but
according to Democrats this is all much
you do about nothing just a touching
story about a father and his love for
his son what a lot of love with a lot of
dollars take a look
thank you Mr chairman and I want to say
thank you to Mr Donald Trump for calling
this hearing today as it demonstrates
the House GOP and Donald Trump's
continued attacks on our institutions
and on our democracy this entire fake
impeachment inquiry isn't about the
United States it's about Hunter Biden
and the only thing the president is can
be guilty of here is being a father but
I will tell you what
guilty of he has unfortunately been
guilty of loving his child
unconditionally and that is the only
evidence that they have brought forward
and honestly I hope and pray that my
parents love me half as much as he loves
his child Donald Trump's impeachment oh
how many impeachments we got two there
how many indictments we got four how
many providing zero zero Donald Trump is
right I'm he's sick of winning he's just
winning running away with it and that's
why we're here we're here because of
math
now despite what you just heard all of
the evidence points to the exact same
thing Hunter Biden selling access to the
Biden brand I don't think the brand was
the guy addicted to cocaine and drugs I
don't think it was him and had no
experience in pretty much anything uh
Joe Biden he was the brand and every
indication is Joe lied to the American
people as a candidate and as the
president repeatedly and regularly and
also that he was an active participant
with these foreign business partners
that he denied even ever talking about
even meeting with the Russian oligarch
and others at Cafe Milano and anyway a
participant that results in what tens
and tens of millions of dollars in the
hands of Biden family members and monies
used to even enrich Joe Biden himself we
have the emails to prove that let's look
at one example according to a 2017 text
message from Hunter the family brand was
quote the family's only asset and Hunter
was not going to give it a away cheap
now for years Hunter purportedly now
sold access to the brand in exchange for
tens of millions in cash gifts diamonds
a sports car to sketchy foreign
Nationals from China Ukraine Russia
Kazakhstan Romania and a number of other
countries now the proceeds directly
benefited Joe Hunter and James Comer
says nine family members in total even
grandchildren I'm sure they work very
very hard to earn that money in oil gas
and coal and other businesses in fact
new evidence from the house Ways and
Means Committee revealed 250 Grand
wired payments originating in Beijing
they're our number one geopolitical
thought aren't they now that listed Joe
Biden's Delaware home as the beneficiary
address those these Chinese payments
were from 2019 when Joe was running for
president and Hunter he was out there
living in Malibu will reckon the homie
was renting according to the landlord
the wire transfers were labeled as quote
personal investment well now it's not
every day that the Communist Party of
China is wiring a mere quarter million
dollars to the home of the U.S
presidential candidate and I'm not even
including the 5.1 after the WhatsApp
message uh that was delivered just Days
Later Democrats they are in concerned
Joe's last name is Biden it's not Donald
Trump it's not Eric Trump it's not
Donald Trump Jr it's not Ivanka Trump so
it's just not a big deal for them uh the
always petulant congressman and Biden
superfan this idiot from New York Dan
Goldman is much more infatuated with his
hatred of legal scholar uh Professor
Jonathan Turley why is that because
professor professor Jonathan Turley
always exposes Goldman uh for who he
truly is a complete idiot look
Mr Turley you said in 2019 that
impeachment requires a clear criminal
act is that right
No in fact in the Trump impeachment I
said repeatedly you can you can impeach
someone for non-criminal conduct what I
said then I'm saying now which is I
strongly encourage you to look at
criminal law all right well that
testimony is there but let's just no you
can't because I have 10 seconds left you
have said that lying as a as a president
is not impeachable
you have said that there's an influence
peddling campaign but you will
acknowledge will you not that in order
to have a criminal act of public
corruption or bribery there must be
under McDonald an official act in
connection to some sort of personal
benefit isn't that right gentleman's
times expired but Charlie please answer
the question I can just point you to my
testimony I talk about quickly just
answer the question because it's a
little more complex no it's not an
official act for a personal benefit
uh gentlemen's times expired now the
congressman is known as own goal uh
Goldman around town because he always
seems to accidentally be bolstering the
claims against the big guy Joe Biden
take a look
you testified that he said to to that
Hunter told his dad according to Rob
Walker quote I may be trying to start a
company or try to do something with
these guys
now let me ask you something that
doesn't sound much like Joe Biden was
involved in whatever Hunter Biden was
doing with the cefc if Hunter Biden is
telling him that he's trying to do
business with them does it
no but it does show that he said he told
his father he was trying to do business
and he was talking well that is true
Hunter Biden does try to do business
that's correct it was clear that it was
part of the daily conversations that
Hunter Biden had with his father
um and it was and and sound is like most
of the time uh
now President Biden didn't even know who
the people he was at dinner he was just
asked to say hello uh and he would you
know talk about the the way he described
it several times they asked over and
over and over he described what the
weather was how uh how what's going on
on your end
so Joe calls Hunter with his foreign
business partners what did they talk
about the weather
anybody believe that
[Music]
now no doubt Dan who's dumb they were
paying Hunter Millions to talk to Pops
and his business partners from other
countries about the weather think about
how much this story has Evolved first
Biden's his supporters said Joe never
once discussed uh business with Hunter
his brother or anybody for that matter
they claimed he then oh like we've been
saying he never participated in business
deals when they changed the story and
then they said sure Biden met with or
talked to Hunter's business partners
occasionally about the weather but just
in passing now then of course they
admitted that Joe frequently engaged
with Hunter's business partners even
went to dinner with oligarchs but just
because Joe is a loving father trying to
help his son Joe never got any of the
money well we have emails that counter
that message here's the message sure Joe
Biden's house was listed as the
beneficiary address for a massive wire
transfer from China while Joe was
running for president and Hunter was
living in California but it's not it's
just not a big deal it's just a wire
transfer it's not like it's physical
cash you'd have to actually go to the
bank and cash the money they gave you
and I'm sure they did now of course in
our you know hyper partisan World
Democrats they'll try almost anything to
defend their president uh but what about
Biden's so-called independent doj what
are they doing don't they investigate
possible crimes Farm bribery corruption
influence peddling and that brings us to
yet that other email from Hunter Biden
according to the house ways a Means
Committee and even CNN is in possession
of an email where Hunter claims that all
of this his legal stuff is going to go
away once that pops becomes president
you know what I think Hunter was on to
something if not for a few government
whistleblowers and a responsible judge
in Delaware Hunter and Joe they wouldn't
have a care in the world but the dojs
were work to protect the big guy began
well before Joe was even sworn in in
2020 the liberal lawyers of the doj they
demanded that investigators scrub all
references to Joe Biden during a
potential Pharaoh warrant notably Hunter
has never been charged with a fair
violation likely because such a crime
would implicate his father he should
talk to Paul manafort and while the doj
acts as the personal legal defense team
for the president the house is actually
investigating Biden over many serious
allegations hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else